In 2022 the whole world was shocked when
Russia actually invaded Ukraine.
However, this was not a
shock to the people of Georgia.
In 2008, Russian tanks invaded,
proclaiming to defend independent
territories of Khazia
and south of Cessia.
In this video, we will break down the
myths and revisionist history that Russia
used to justify this invasion.
We will see that they don't hold up to
historical scrutiny.
And I will link the sources below so you
can look at them yourself.
It all starts centuries ago, in the 10th
century after Christ, King
Bachrath III unifies Abkhazia
with other Georgian
territories under one royal crown.
In the 1800s the Russian Empire invades
and takes over the
Caucasus, Georgia included.
1921 Soviet maps place Abkhazia and South
Prosthesia firmly
inside of Georgian territory.
In the 1990s, after the fall of the
Soviet Union, separatist wars break out.
Russia sends in peacekeepers and claims
to help to control
and calm down the area.
In 2008 Russia launches a full-scale
invasion into Georgia,
forcing Georgia to more or less
recognize Ossetia and Abkhazia as
independent territories.
Let's start with the biggest one.
The evil charters list Abkhazia as being
part of the Georgian kingdom.
Over a thousand years ago, in 1926 Soviet
maps place Abkhazia
and South Ossetia firmly
into the Georgian Soviet Republic.
That is false, archives from 1921 show
the current borders.
In 1931 Abkhazia was merely made an
autonomous republic inside of Georgia.
That is a serious
accusation and it's plainly false.
The Tagliavinny report states
that yes, 162 civilians died.
But that is far removed from the 2000
civilian deaths that the
Russian Ministry of Defense
claims.
A claim, by the way, that was then later
very quietly revised
down to only 133 deaths.
Meanwhile over 200,000 ethnic Georgians
were cleansed from their
homes in the two regions.
There was no referendum.
Russia started handing out passports in
2002 as the groundwork for an invasion.
They were creating Russian citizens in
Abkhazia and Ossetia so
that they could later claim
to protect them.
Language doesn't
justify legal justification.
Abkhazia's constitution prioritizes
Abkhaz and Russia is only
listed as the second language.
This claim is absurd, otherwise Spain
would have a claim to
invade all of Latin America
almost.
Russia rehearsed their invasion in July
2008, this was weeks
before the NATO summit was
held where talks of
Georgia joining NATO flared up.
And yes, it's not a surprise that
countries like Finland and
Sweden, who were historically
neutral, looked towards NATO after
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
Peacekeepers don't drop cluster bombs.
The European Union called Russia's
invasion disproportionate.
They bombed civilian areas outside of the
war zone and they violated the ceasefire.
The European Commission for Human Rights
from 2021 confirms this.
Only five countries recognize them.
Russia funds over 90% of South Ossetia's
budget, controls the
borders and even stations
FSB guards.
That is not independence, it's just
occupation with extra paperwork.
Does this sound familiar?
It should.
Passportization, false genocide,
peacekeeper covers, all copy paste
playbook from Crimea
and Donbas.
Myths can change, but
tactics stay the same.
That's why history matters.
Find all the cited
documents in the description.
If this helped you at all to understand
what is going on or if you
learned something, please
hit like, subscribe, comment with a myth
you want me to tackle next.
I have a lot of time and a lot of myths
to cover, so we will
tackle all of them eventually.